it's all volcanic basically almost
everything there has been created by
volcanoes and glaciers and so you have
all this beautiful uplift
where kilometer basalt is created and
then like everything wears away and it's
left there and it's kind of like
hanging teeth almost like a some
medieval castle and
that's what's so weird is that when
you're there you're walking through this
landscape
it's one of the youngest on earth and
you feel it
like you feel that intimacy that
closeness with it
so in the wake of that cycling
experience like how does that
change or inform your world view or like
how you think about
the creative process you know what's so
interesting was i
i as much as it was just amazing to do
and experience
sharing it was so valuable and showing
people that
like i come from relatively no
experience i'm not
a gifted you know cyclist in any regard
i'm not a
i mean if anything i've learned how to
take a photograph and and
make a film but to be able to kind of
understand
and share with people that in order to
truly know a place an experience that
you have to subject yourself to it in
some way you have to be willing to and i
think that
that experience of sharing the story
of the race of the training of all those
things and my commitment to
place my commitment to experience i mean
i i will sum
all that up is like i didn't ride a bike
to get exercise
i didn't ride a bike to stay up for 66
hours or to burn 35 000 calories
i rode a bike because i wanted to know
what it felt like
to have to be so insignificant in an
environment that i
love and to feel so small to remind
myself of what that's like
because that's what it felt like the
first time i was there and so
we look for opportunities to do that in
our life and i'm not saying the bar
needs to constantly be raised and
the risk needs to constantly be elevated
but i i do feel like there's moments in
your life when you realize like
the time is now like there's never going
to be another window
and i think what i what i hope people
kind of can
understand from that is like i turn
down work to do that you know learning
to say no is really learning to say yes
to what you want and
um as somebody who has been a yes man
their whole life because i was
raised by a mom and my dad who basically
like
super blue collar and any work that came
was good and
and i still witnessed that that hard
work ethic today
like saying no to work was was not even
on my radar
so to realize that i've gotten this
place in my career where i have the
ability to
maybe say no to something in order to
give myself to something i really want
was a really beautiful experience and
that's where i just felt
like the real learning happened and
occurred right
yeah i mean i think that comes part and
parcel with success you know the
drive to advance your craft requires
saying yes to so much
you know that's part of what it means to
build a career like just
doing stuff for free always being
available and all of that and then you
reach a certain inflection point
and you can't do that anymore that will
bury you right so you have to develop
these boundaries and learn how to say
no to things and and and and develop
that sense of
clarity about what's most important and
that's the part nobody teaches you
nobody teaches you how to say no i mean
everything all the workshops out there
everything are like how to say yes how
to you know but and how to be more
efficient but that's been the hardest
thing is like
realizing that statement like saying no
is saying yes to what you want and i
said yes something i wanted and it
it gave me a beautiful gift and it gave
me a sense of
pride and a sense of that and i think
this is what it comes back to is we're
looking for validation in everything we
do that's the world that's
that's like growing up in 2020 is
is social media is just a sense of
validation and everything we do and so
well you know you can share something
and have millions of people like it and
it's that i have to remind myself okay
real validation doesn't come from
an app doesn't come from people that
don't truly know you i think it comes
from making somebody
proud feeling love feeling that intimacy
feeling that connection to place feeling
that connection to story
and maybe in some ways riding your bike
850 miles around the country
feeling some sense of um a greater
purpose that you know
you worked for this and you achieved
this that's something i feel like i'm
constantly searching for in my life
in different ways well there's a
fidelity to your value system like i
look at that bike race
as a close cousin to the decision to get
into a vw van and go up and down the
coast like these are
relate these are not unrelated um you
know inspirations right
it's like it's a way of recapturing the
innocence of
that experience by putting yourself in
an environment that's
unfamiliar to you and the learning that
comes and the humanizing storytelling
aspect of it by you know capturing these
austere environments and
translating the meaning of that
through you know your emotional
landscape
in a way that connects with people that
makes them feel like
you know as i said at the outset like i
feel connected to you because of your
ability to
storytell in that way
[Music]
you